بينما تعمل الجرافات لازاله الركام وانقاذ
الارواح في مكان اخر بالعالم تحول جرافات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بيوت الفلسطينيين في
القدس الى ركام هنا يجد الفلسطيني نفسه
امام سلطه تمنع عنه تراخيص البناء وفي
الوقت ذاته تهدم له بيته بحجه البناء دون
ترخيص وفي حاله ابو ادهم تهدم له ولابنائه
ثلاثه منازل في وقت واحد
وكله من تعبنا وشكانا يعني احنا احنا
جماعه بنشتغل قصدين باب الله
والكرش بعز علينا والشجر بعز علينا وتعبوا
اولادنا برضه والوقت الحالي احنا مشردين
يعني بالعربي فش مسكن
قوات كبيره طوقت المنطقه وحاصرت العائلات
وخلال عمليه الهدم كانت تقمع سكان الحي
وتعتدي عليهم ورغم ضجيج الهدم وصوت
القنابل ظل صوت اصحاب المنازل مسموعا
قوات الاحتلال تنسحب الان بعد ان انهت
عمليه تدمير المنازل دقائق قليله استغرقها
هدمه كل منزل وتشريد اصحابه مقابل سنوات
من العمل ليتمكن اصحابها من بنائها و
ايواء عائلاتهم
ولتامين انسحابها قامت قوات الاحتلال
باطلاق الاعيره المطاطيه وقنابل الغاز
المسيل للدموع ما ادى الى اندلاع مواجهات
مع الشبان الفلسطينيين اوقعت عددا من
الاصابات من بينها اصابه مصور الجزيره
الزميل وائل السلايمي في استهداف مباشر
للاطقم الصحفيه
الاف المنازل يتهددها الهدم في القدس
المحتله بذريعه عدم الترخيص ومع تهديدات
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه بتكثيف
عمليات الهدم يزداد شعور الفلسطيني بانه
وحيد في معركه غير متوازنه يواجه فيها كل
انواع السلاح والتهجير بعلاقته مع الارض
نجوان سمري الجزيره من بلده جبل المكبر
القدس المحتله